was geht hier ist euer cani und heute
spielen wir ein ründchen turbo tismer
und wer das spiel noch nicht kennt das
ist relativ lustig es geht darum dass
man so einen crash tami hat und damit
möglichst viel schaden bekommt und
möglichst viele sachen kaputt macht also
ein ziemliches dummkopf spielen das
lustige daran ist hier customization du
kannst den leuten total dumme gesichter
reinpacken ich habe mal ein paar bilder
gemacht und die werde jetzt mal
einstellen habe ich sagen wir gleich mal
los zu ich würde sagen wir wären mal die
karte schicken twist einfach und als
fahrzeug nehmen wir den puls tröpfelte
den charakteren auf jeden fall sehr
treffend verehrt natürlich angst jetzt
kaputt zu gehen und dann probleme unser
glück ich glaube es gibt diesen kurs den
anfang muss aber probieren das direkt
mal anders zu machen hält lenker michael
menke doch werden nicht gesenkt nochmal
gott oh gott lenkt er von selbst
und das coole daran ist man kann doch
wie so oft die adwords reinpacken
ob sechs kamera einpacken und die kann
man ganz lustig macht sie packen es zum
beispiel mal die big rembrandt goya das
so eine gute idee
und dann drehen wir die mal ein bisschen
weil sie es geht ja wie gesagt hier bei
darum dass man möglichst viel schaden
kriegt und darf ich sagen das passt
schon und wir legen los okay er lenkt
anscheinend von selbst da verhängt so
schön kopfüber da
okay das war schnell kaputt so freuen
wir suchen sich irgendeine strecke aus
wo wir richtig schön damage machen
können
nehmen wir look to you und ich habe
jemanden passendes ausgesucht das auch
wenn wir gleich hinfahren und ja und
jetzt nehmen wir irgendwo richtig
schnell des fahrzeugs ulrike bücker
das klingt gut und hier kann man sogar
selbst steuern genau wollen probieren
denn du zwar gut schaden zu machen
oh gott
oh gott das war nicht gut
aber wie heißt aber sorry luca
full speed
vielleicht schaffen wir das sei erst der
blick auf steht das ist definitiv ein
neuer highscore freunde und da vorne
lief programm ließen im letzte kammer
das ist wirklich
falls ja schon ich wusste ich bin ein
superheld denn ich kann meine orte
abstellen
und so wie es ein lustiges bild gemacht
und dann werden wir schauen ob wir damit
weiter fliegen können als sonst ins
letzte fassung dazu habe ich jetzt noch
diesen vogel ausgewählt aber ist dass
wir das hinter uns steht der kopf sich
kopfüber okay wir machen gleich einmal
so nen richtigen buch soll ihr der reihe
nach packen wir alle boost sachen
dahinter und dann vielleicht noch ein
minenfeld das was wir rechtlich richtig
lustig wenn wir das mit luca machen
müssen
dafür nehmen wir nochmal dieses richtig
schnell sind wieder okay
der provinz aus sogar übertrifft
es ist heftiger erst so schnell am
anfang und jetzt
wir probieren es nochmal das klang
richtig übel daran erkennbar dass wenn
also ich freu mich so sagen
verdient der neue high score und so
freundlich sie mir wieder besuchen
übrigen kappe aufgezogen wir suchen uns
jetzt mal eine richtig schöne als
schaukel aus die fan zu sein wird es
aller lust ist und jetzt fangen wir mal
so ganz gemächlich in den straßenverkehr
ein etwas tun sonst hätten wir keine
ahnung von nichts und tram einfach
probieren vielleicht nicht mal leute zu
rahmen vorschlag worte [ __ ] vorm
explodieren die weiter- oder okay du
bist
okay ich habe mir das noch ja freunde
und wie immer ist es neue high score wie
immer wenn einfach nur das spiel anfasse
mal dinge los
und
das kann aber es war nicht mal so
schlecht schilder einfach drin weil wir
können wir gar nichts
so sieht das aus meiner sicht aus gerade
also was meiner sicht es ist eine sehr
schöne runde gewesen leute ich hab es
hat euch gefallen aber mal wieder was
anderes und ich bin so froh dass es
endlich geklappt hat es aufzunehmen
wenn es dann geklappt hat aber das sehe
ich gleich habe nicht gefallen wenn ja
dass man leichter und die sehen uns bei
diesmal wieder auf freien fuß